[Music]
lately
i've been alone
[Music]
alone with my thoughts
alone with my fears
just
alone
the desert can be beautiful like that
there are roads that lead to nowhere and
places you can go where you won't see
another soul
dave leads in tonight and night leads in
today
until time itself just
kind of fades away
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i spent most of april and nearly all of
may alone
reading walking writing
i just kind of hid away from the world
trying to make sense of things
i had a hard time motivating myself to
do anything work related much less to
create
i sat in silence and thought a lot about
the life i was living
i felt
whatever it was i needed to feel and did
my best to avoid distraction
[Music]
it was difficult
[Music]
but also healing
and beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
it's always there
watching
steadfast
knowing us in our light and dark moments
changing forever
just as we do
[Music]
every day it's a different version of
itself
sometimes weak
sometimes strong and full of light
the moon knows what it means to be human
uncertain
alone
cratered by imperfection
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you to moon for sponsoring this
video
some of you might have noticed that my
fan doesn't have a roof rack so when
moon offered to send me their moon shade
awning i was surprised to learn that it
didn't require roof rack or any kind of
permanent attachment
moonshade is a portable awning that can
easily mount to all kinds of rigs it
attaches pretty easily using a variety
of methods there are magnets or suction
cups and they work great with rv schooly
truck camper van you name it it takes
about five minutes to set up packs down
to roughly the size of a yoga mat and
weighs just eight pounds also side note
the mount comes in really handy for
hanging my shower bag as well this is
where i store the moon awning and it
fits perfectly right here in the
passenger side it's in there nice and
snug and i use the magnetic anchors to
hold it in place adding a moon shade to
my rake has improved my home in a few
ways extra living space a solution for
hanging my shower and an awning to
escape the summer heat which makes it
pretty perfect for road life
check out the link in my caption below
to pick up your own moon shade and
thanks again to moon for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
somewhere in there a two-week pet sit in
park city utah became available and the
thought of snow-capped mountains and
cooler weather sounded like heaven
and it was
[Music]
i wasn't alone for this set which was
nice because it also happened to be my
birthday
i turned 37
i think if you would have told 17 year
old me that when i turned 37 i would be
living in my car
alone working as a self-employed artist
i think i would have burst into tears
obviously there's more to it but on
paper those are the facts
17 year old me would have expected 37
year old me to have her life together to
be living overseas climbing the
corporate ladder living in a big
beautiful modern home married with a dog
and 2.5 kids
that wasn't exactly my idea of happiness
but i believed it was what i was
supposed to want
the truth is i have actually experienced
most of those things in the past 20
years and a hell of a lot more
but those things don't guarantee
happiness
happiness is an inside job as they say
still i'm so grateful for all of it
because it has all led
to here
the great wide empty
miles and miles of open road
freedom golden light and starry nights
a subtle yet steady shift away from
society and all the expectations that
come with it
[Music]
i know it won't last forever
but for now
i'm leaning in
to the solitude
the
unknown and everything in between
as i head into my fifth year of living
full-time on the road i've learned a few
things
actually i could probably create a whole
video on what i've learned but if i were
to summarize it would be this
the road has taught me to notice rather
than to search
to appreciate rather than to analyze
to accept that i'm on a journey to
nowhere and
everywhere all at once
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for now these roads to nowhere are my
home
these wild spaces
are my classroom
and every person challenge and joy i
find along the way
is my teacher
one way or another
so here's to four years on the road
37 years on this earth
and everything new that lies ahead
and here's to you for being here
thank you
and i'll see you soon